hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
you can see we have all sorts of
questions saved up here um
let's see there's one from mouse123
that asks how much does a cat's tail
affect their ability to land on their
feet do cats without tails tend to fall
over more frequently
okay so first
observation
and i have to admit
i i think i might have tried this when i
was a kid
but i have a cat but i haven't had a cat
for
ever
and uh but if you hold the cat
upside down
and uh
and then you drop it the cat will
swivel around and land on its feet and
it manages to do that even from a fairly
low height
and the question is how does it do it
and i remember years ago
a
mathematics professor i knew
was making fun of one of her colleagues
because uh this colleague had a whole
elaborate theory of how
cats land on their feet and the theory
had to do with the twirling of the tail
of the cat
and and she observed that actually cats
without tails like monks type cats and
so on also managed to land on their feet
so any theory of cats
twirling in the air based on their tails
has to be the wrong story i mean it's
worth pointing out
that tales are pretty important for
balance
in general i mean lots of creatures that
uh you know
are the you know the tree dwelling
creatures that jump from here to there
they make use of their tails um in in
balancing
um
uh we humans clearly do not
have tails
and um the uh
uh
and yet we still manage to balance and i
i think that's a
uh i suspect we're not
we're not you have to be a very special
human to be able to balance and jump
from tree to tree um most humans can't
do that i mean it's worth commenting
that in general the importance of tails
for things
uh
is
is great like an airplane for example uh
you might say well all that matters to
an airplane is its wings that's what's
gonna hold the airplane up but actually
its tail is really important
in maintaining its essentially its its
balance and maintaining weight forces so
that for example the airplane for
example when an airplane
goes up what's happening is that the the
um
the
horizontal stabilizer things on the tail
uh they actually go up and that pushes
the tail of the airplane down which
causes the nose of the airplane to go up
which put causes the wings to be have a
uh to sort of have a larger angle of
attack to be to be sort of pointed more
upwards which pushes which allows the
airplane to then go up
so you know tails are important but
cats somehow don't need them
in being able to uh turn themselves the
right way up i think that if you look at
videos of cats
uh sort of
in in motion in the air
that the big thing they're using
is
uh various kinds of angular momentum
conservation because once once you're a
falling cat
it's not like you get to
kind of push against something you
simply have to use kind of
uh
pure
effects that have to do with sort of
intrinsic effects associated with the
the cat
not something where you get to sort of
touch the wall and and change your
orientation
and okay so so actually this lets me
talk about another thing
which is things like gyroscopes
so
normally i mean one of the basic facts
about mechanics it's newton's first law
is that if you just set something in
motion in a straight line you don't act
on it with any force it will just keep
going in that straight line at the same
speed
that wasn't something super obvious
probably in the 1600s when newton first
formulated that principle because at
that time most of the things that you
would find kind of
lying around
uh you know on the street type thing
with things where there'd be very high
friction and so it wouldn't be the case
that the thing if you set it in motion
you'd actually have to keep pushing it
to have it keep going because it would
otherwise stop because of friction
but
we know that
for example in when there's no air
resistance you're in the vacuum of space
you're in and you don't have there's no
gravity acting on you things do just
keep going in a straight line and what
you didn't realize one of the one of the
non-trivial things he realized was that
that idealization of no friction
no forces acting on something
that that was a reasonable idealization
to think about and in that idealization
that things would just keep going in a
straight line so that's the conservation
of linear momentum so the momentum of
the thing
is uh it's mathematically equal to the
mass times the velocity and the velocity
is something which has a direction as
well as a magnitude so it's like you
keep going with that mass and that
velocity now by the way that equation
for
uh when you think about mass and
velocity and so on things get more
complicated when you have something like
a rocket which can change its mass
because it's ejecting rocket
it's ejecting
something behind it and so on and that
gets all more complicated but then what
is the case in the end is this idea of
momentum and conservation so that's
linear momentum going in a straight line
so there's another kind of momentum
which is angular momentum which is
momentum associated with rotation
and so when you have
uh
the there is also
a
conservation of angular momentum so if
you have something spinning around it
will keep spinning until it's acted on
not by an ordinary force which is
pushing it to one side but a torque
which is a twisting kind of force
and so when you have something that's
spinning around
and it has some
uh
the um it has a certain angular momentum
it will keep spinning around unless
there's friction that slows it down
which effectively exerts a torque
if um uh if the um
to decode the british accent it's
t-o-r-q-u
um the uh
the uh
when um
uh when you have something which is just
spinning around it will keep spinning
around so let's say you have i don't
know something like a bicycle wheel and
it's not on the ground and just sort of
start it off and you keep it spinning
around it will just keep spinning around
um
and until it slows down because of
friction but if it didn't have friction
it would just keep spinning around
and that's a consequence of this idea of
conservation of angular momentum
same thing by the way
uh
it's um
uh when you have the earth going around
in its orbit you can think of that
as just keeping going because of the
conservation of angular momentum
so
the um
uh and and you can ask questions about
so what is the
the conservation of angle meant leads to
all kinds of effects
so for example if you if you take a
bicycle wheel and you just hold on you
spin it around and you have it mounted
on an axle you hold on to the axle you
try and turn the axle around the axle it
will be difficult to turn the axle
because
of this idea of conservation momentum
the thing wants to keep on spinning in
the same way but if you turn the axle
then it will be spinning with respect to
a different axis and that's a different
angle momentum
from a a math point of view um
let's see how to decode this the the the
official math version of what is angular
momentum
it's
uh r cross p if p is the is the ordinary
momentum of something going around in a
circle let's say
um that is a certain it's a certain
vector direction it's a momentum with a
certain direction and there's also a
radius that goes from the center of
rotation out to the thing
and then you take a vector cross product
of those things and what that that gives
you another vector that points at 90
degrees to the other two vectors and
that is the angular momentum vector and
that's eventually the thing that is
conserved in conservation and momentum
so it's it's like if you take the wheel
spinning around um the angular momentum
is kind of like an axle through the
wheel it's it's the it's it's a thing
where if the wheel is spinning clockwise
for example the angular momentum vector
the egg will be pointing sort of up
along the direction of the axle if it
was spinning the other way down
you're pointing down
along the axle but that axle defines
that direction of the axle defines the
the direction of the angular momentum
uh vector
and and the um the magnitude that is
determined by the rate at which the
thing is going around the mass the
distance out to that mass
so
in any case the the um so what
consequence does it have well for
example if you have a top for instance a
top will just keep spinning because of
conservation momentum it will keep
spinning until uh friction causes it to
slow down and eventually fall over but
if it doesn't if if there's if one
doesn't have friction it kind of seems
like a magic thing because it keeps
spinning and it keeps being being sort
of on its little little point that it's
spinning on and it seems to be sort of
uh resisting the force of gravity well
it is because the the um uh the sort of
the force of gravity will be trying to
change the angular momentum direction
and that that's something that uh takes
it it's difficult to do that so to speak
actually the motion of tops is a really
complicated thing in the late 1800s it
was kind of the this sort of top fancy
mathematical thing that you could work
out using the laws of mechanics
and there are all kinds of lovely terms
there's this thing called the pole hold
and the hurple hold
which are aspects that describe
kind of the the precise way in which a
top will move around so so one of the
big things that happens with the top is
a phenomenon called procession
where normally you have the direction of
a momentum vector kind of the axle of
the top is pointing let's say up and
spin the top around it does its thing
now let's say you act on the top with
for example gravity what will happen is
as soon as the as soon as that axis of
rotation is not quite vertical it will
start processing around so in other
words the axis of rotation will itself
rotate around at a certain rate
and that's a general feature of spinning
things
and the way that and when forces act on
spinning things that axis of rotation if
if it does start to if if it isn't sort
of precisely aligned if the axis is not
precisely aligned
then forces will cause that axis to
process around
and in fact um that happens even for the
earth
it happens um
uh the the earth is spinning around but
the earth um and this is it's again it's
kind of complicated the geometry the
earth the axis of the earth is 23
degrees away
from the uh from the plane defined by
the orbit of the earth around the sun
so that's the um uh
the
plane of the ecliptic
is that's the term
for the plane defined by the sun is at
the center and the earth is going around
its orbit it's called the plane of the
ecliptic because it relates to eclipses
because you get an eclipse when the moon
is lined up in front of the earth
obstructing the sun but that all happens
in this plane where the earth's orbit um
goes where the earth orbits relative to
the sun so the earth is is some uh
the um
um
uh the angle of the earth relative to
the plane of the ecliptic
which has a name
uh is it obliquity i think it might be
obliquity
um
is the is the term
for and different planets have different
uh different angles
that their rotation axis is relative to
the um
uh
to the plane of the ecliptic to the orb
to the plane that they orbit the sun
around i mean one one of the features of
our solar system is and it seems to be
true of exoplanet solar systems as well
that the planets tend to orbit in the
same plane
it's like the sun was formed the star
was formed at the center the star is
actually itself rotating around at a
certain rate and there was kind of a
disc of material formed around the star
which eventually aggregated into planets
and so everything is more or less in one
plane
um for example pluto is a little bit out
of the plane of the ecliptic um and uh
that kind of suggests different things
about its origin and so on
but um relative to that plane most
planets uh kind of have their axis of
rotation more or less aligned so that
they're kind of rolling around like cogs
as they go around
around in the orbit for example uranus
has its
uh has its axis of rotation more or less
upside down um perhaps suggesting it had
a collision with some other planet at
some point but different angles anyway
the earth 23 degrees from the plane of
the ecliptic and the earth like a top
uh shows procession
uh its procession period is twenty
twenty three thousand years and
three twenty four thousand years uh
around that order twenty two twenty
three twenty four thousand years i've
forgotten exactly how much
um and that is the uh that leads to a
phenomenon called the procession of the
equinoxes
um
which is
uh
let's see that leads to all kinds of
different things it leads to uh what the
north pole star will be because the
earth's axis is processing around that
means that which star will be in the
kind of northern direction right now
it's polaris as the is the star closest
to the north pole but it wasn't always
that way and uh uh you know 12 000 years
ago uh it was kind of the the polaris
was quite far off it was probably 40
something degrees away from the the
direction of the north of the of north
in the sky
so uh in any case this phenomenon of
procession is um uh
is is a general phenomenon associated
with um forces on things that are
spinning around
um so the question originally was about
cats
and i don't know you know the cat
doesn't get to make a full spin around
that was what this kind of
discredited theory of cats twirling
their tails as a way to land on their
feet had to do with um but the fact is
that you still get effects due to
hanging momentum conservation even when
you are just pivoting even when you've
got your you know four sets of four legs
and you're sort of pivoting the legs
relative to each other that still gives
you similar makes use of similar kinds
of physics
um beyond that i don't really know the
the um uh the detail of um i mean i've
seen videos of what cats do um exactly
understanding how that works is pretty
complicated um and i don't know whether
there are robots that land on their feet
the same way that cats do there
certainly should be by in today's world
that should exist i don't know if it
does i mean the the main issue with many
of these things is like drones where
they have four propellers you know a
quadcopter drone that has four
propellers the biggest issue with is you
take a drone and just push down on one
side of the drone the propeller that's
on that side better be start spinning
more rapidly to push that side of the
drone up but the drone kind of has to
know which side was pushed down and at
what rate to increase the speed of the
propeller and for example it better not
over overshoot and keep the propellers
spinning faster because then that side
of the drone will go up you know you
pushed it down and then it's trying to
push itself up but then if it overshoots
it'll push itself way up and then the
other side the other side will go down
and bad things will result there's some
instability that results that was
finally like a decade ago roughly um it
started to be the case that
microelectronics was ready to actually
be able to put flight controllers inside
drones i don't know if a flight
controller for a robot cat has been made
but i think it could be made at this
point
and i don't think it matters that the
cat
is um is kind of made of cat tissue so
to speak i suspect that you could do it
with just purely um like uh like like
like rods that represent the legs of the
cat and things like this i think you
should be able to make that work and you
have some number of motors that
represent the muscles inside the cat um
and i think with the i think it should
be possible to make something which will
land on its feet a robot a robot cap
that will land on its feet
so
um
let's see
the um
uh there's another question here from
there's a question here from aaron about
could a planet have internal rotation of
its molten core while having stagnant
outer surface
perhaps a slowly rotating surface
yes absolutely the core of
the the um
uh
planetary cause
so okay so our planet the earth has a
molten core
um
why is it molten two basic effects
one is it still hasn't solidified since
it was formed four and a half billion
years ago
it's it's still waiting there's it's
like it's a pretty good insulator rock
is a pretty good insulator and so the
heat from inside the earth
from when the earth was originally
formed from lots of things aggregating
together and being sort of scrunched
together by gravity that produced lots
of heat and that heat hasn't all escaped
yet from the interior of the earth and
that's why the earth is hot inside
that's about half the reason the earth
is hot inside the other half of the
reason is there are radioactive elements
that are again left over
from well left over from from the
formation of the earth they were created
uh some of them uh mostly created in in
stars that exploded before the earth was
formed before the sun was formed the sun
is not a first generation star the sun
is makes use of material that was
recycled from previous generations of
stars that exploded before the sun was
formed and some of those elements like
uranium for example
that get formed in those kinds of
explosions and related phenomena
those things got included inside the
earth but those elements gradually decay
they gradually the nuclei of those atoms
gradually explode and when they explode
they produce heat um and
the the sort of
half the uranium for example it took oh
i don't know a couple of billion years
for even half of it to have decayed so
we're only 4.6 billion years out from
the beginning so there's still a bunch
of uranium left over from the very
beginning because it just it halves the
amount of uranium every i forget what it
is every a couple of billion years or so
um and so it's gradually halving but
it's not reached zero so about half the
heat of the earth is associated with
radioactive elements decaying and half
as is relic heat from when the earth was
formed but the bottom line is the earth
is hot inside
and it's a tricky thing because it's hot
inside but it's also higher and higher
and higher pressure as you get closer to
the center it's like when you go into
the ocean
at the top of the ocean
the the pressure you know if you're just
hanging out at the beach
the pressure exerted on your body is
just from the air and it's just the same
as ordinary atmospheric pressure
if you dive down in the ocean
then the pressure that's exerted in your
body is not just the pressure of the air
it's also the pressure of water that's
pushing on every side of you and as you
go deeper in the water
the amount of pressure increases because
effectively the weight of water above
you is pressing down on you and the way
it works with the liquid it presses down
on all sides of you not just on the top
of you so to speak
and so as you go down in the ocean it
rapidly gets i forget um well the
atmospheric pressure is 33 feet
um down into an ocean that's that's the
the complete pressure associated with
all the air that's above you in the
atmosphere is the equivalent of um
uh
all right yeah
um
yeah 760 millimeters of mercury i think
it's 33 feet of water um
the uh that corresponds to the pressure
that would double the pressure on you so
if you're diving then you get sort of
double of atmospheric pressure when you
go that deep the the deepest oceans are
like seven miles deep um like the
marianas trench off of
japan is is the deepest point and it's
that that deep um and the pressure is
incredibly much higher there we could
try and work out what it is but we just
have to divide um the pressure just um
uh
yeah the pressure just increases
well it's not quite linear with depth
because the density of sea water changes
with depth
because the the sea water itself is
being somewhat compressed
um but uh and also the salt uh content
of the sea water changes there's a thing
called the standard ocean you can find
both mouthful will compute these things
and tell you the um the pressure at any
depth in an ocean of any salinity that's
the amount of salt in the water
and the different different oceans like
the atlantic the pacific and so on they
will have slightly different amounts of
salt because it depends on how much rock
has been dissolved into the water and on
all those kinds of things but basic
bottom line is that as you go down in
the ocean the pressure gets uh very high
um and uh uh you know if you're if
you're a deep sea fish for example
living down at the in the depths of the
ocean the innards of you are exerting a
lot of pressure out to stop the water
that's outside you crushing you in and
i'm afraid one one sort of sad fact
about about this is when people first
started getting deep sea fish
um i remember when i was a kid the books
that illustrated you know what did deep
sea fish look like they always showed
spherical fish
well the reason they showed spherical
fish is because when you take a fish
that was used to living a mile below the
surface of water and you pull it up to
the surface the pressure inside the fish
is very big and so the fish will
will you know come out like a balloon
because there's a lot of pressure inside
it not
not compensated by pressure coming from
the outside but i think when you go down
in a in a submarine uh to the people
have gone down to the very bottom of the
ocean in these actual spherical shape
submarines um and uh the fish are not
spherical there that's that was a sort
of a mistake
from uh from the way that they were
observed so to speak that there they
have a certain pressure inside them and
that pressure is compensated by the
pressure of the water outside and the
fish are just fish shaped or whatever
so
uh in any case the um
uh
let's see we're talking about pressure
and i was saying that inside the earth
there is also pressure from all the rock
that's on top of you as if you go
further closer to the center of the
earth there'll be all this rock on top
of you
that is exerting pressure
now again it gets more complicated
because you have to look at the amount
of gravity because eventually when
you're at the very center of the earth
the the gravity that is
that is is there's gravity that is
associated with the mass on one side of
you and the mass on the other side of
you so actually there's no gravity at
the very center of the earth because the
gravity is sort of pulling you equally
in all directions which means that the
sum of that is no gravity at all so for
example if you drill the hole through
the whole earth
and you drop something through that hole
and it would be
it would speed up for a while as it as
it feels the gravity of the earth but as
it gets the center of the earth it would
not be speeding up anymore um and
actually as it comes out the other side
it would be slowing down because what
will be happening is would it would have
would have developed speed because it
was accelerating towards the center at
the center it would not be changing its
speed anymore and as it comes out the
other side would eventually be pulled
back up by so to speak by the gravity of
the earth sort of pulling it up if you
dropped it down at the top it would be
pulled down by gravity at the top but as
it goes through the other side of the
earth it would now be pulled up by
gravity and so it would eventually come
to eventually halt stop at the other
side of the earth and it would oscillate
back and forth through this big hole
that you draw on the earth
but in any case when you when you put a
bunch of these effects together the end
result is there's high pressure at the
center of the earth on the material
that's there
and and here's the thing
when if you take so once used to things
like i don't know water for example
you say
uh water you cool it down below zero
degrees centigrade it will make ice
but
what makes water make ice well
it's that the the molecules of the water
are kind of crushed together that
they're arranged together so that
they're in this regular array which is
ice
but one way you can get that is by
making the molecules sort of bounce
around less
with by having a lower temperature
another way you can get that is by just
squashing the water a lot until
eventually the molecules are just forced
they can't jump around like they do in
liquid they kind of have to be arranged
like they are in ice and and one of the
tricky things about ice is there are
many different forms of ice i think
they're like at least 40 different forms
of ice that are known in which the water
molecules are arranged in different ways
ordinary ice that we see and that's in
typical snowflakes the molecules are
arranged in this particular hexagonal
pattern but there are different forms of
ice that you see in glaciers that are
under high pressure and things like that
and i think there are like 40 different
forms that are known so far but the atom
where the molecules rearrange themselves
in any case the the point is that when
you put high pressure on something when
you make something very cold the
molecules slow down the molecules will
tend to just get locked together to make
a solid but you can also get a solid by
just pushing with very high pressure and
that's what happens so when you have
something even if it's very hot uh if
you push it hard enough eventually it
will become solid and so that's what
happens in the in the earth um again
there's even more complexity because the
different materials
uh that are in the earth have gradually
sort of separated eye out so the earth
has a nickel iron poor um the very
center of the earth is a solid thing
then there's liquid that's kind of
liquid rock um that's most of the mantle
of the earth the liquid part of the
earth
so the liquid part of the earth has
currents in it
just like and there's slow motion
of that liquid rock when i say liquid if
you think about the pouring a piece of
the the innards of the earth i don't
think it pours very well i think it's
very very syrupy i think it's very very
viscous but it nevertheless sort of
flows at a certain rate
um
you you see
well um
yeah when you see lava coming out of
volcanoes it's kind of the stuff more or
less the stuff that's inside the earth
and and that flows at certain rates and
it's um again a different different
story but um
you asked about some things motion
inside the earth well yes there is
motion inside the mantle of the earth
there are essentially currents just like
their ocean currents just like their
wind uh just like there are trade winds
and things and
the motion in the atmosphere there's
motion in the ocean there's motion in
the in the mantle of the earth
what is the result of the motion in the
mantle of the earth people think that
that's very related to the magnetic
field of the earth the earth uh acts a
bit like a bar magnet that's why we can
make a magnetic compass and have a
needle point towards the north or the
south um the question is what produces
that
uh that magnetic field and it's thought
to be associated with essentially
currents in the center of the earth due
to these due to the motion of things in
the earth
um
that are producing that and i think the
um so the question is could one have a
planet where the innards in a sense
that's happening in the earth there is a
current inside the earth there's motion
inside the earth different from the
motion of the whole earth outside now
could one have something where there is
a a sort of a a core that's spinning
around once a day inside a planet
um i think that's somewhat unlikely but
not impossible the reason i think it's
somewhat unlikely is the viscosity the
kind of friction associated with liquid
motion that happens inside liquid rock
is probably too high to allow something
like that to occur um so it would tend
to be a slower motion of the thing
inside
but maybe the planet maybe the whole
planet might be spinning slowly i mean
the earth
has been the earth is spinning now
because it was always spinning it's
gradually slowing down
but um it was
it was spinning the earth 24-hour uh uh
time
the rotation time of the earth it's not
quite 24 hours
but um uh it depends on how you measure
it whether it's to fixed stars or
relative to its place in its orbit and
so on uh difficult geometry again
but but the the earth
has been gradually slowing down in its
rotation primarily because of the effect
of the moon
um and i'm not sure
let's see i think
uh when there were dinosaurs around
the day
i'm not sure how much shorter it was i i
don't think it was half as half as long
as it is today but it was definitely
shorter than it is today and a shorter
day means the earth is spinning around
more often so it's uh it's sort of
seeing the sun and not seeing the sun
more frequently
so that's some
let's say um
uh
a small comment about that
let's see
um
there's a
comment from memes here what's the deal
with the
zan nebuchov effect the observation that
cosmology had when spinning a bolt
flipped it with a spinning bolt flipped
in space i do not have any idea i don't
know
um
the uh um
kind of the story of
of
of kind of effects that happen in
weightlessness
you know what what in if you're an orbit
around the earth
you're basically continually everything
you're continually falling towards the
earth
and but you don't hit the earth because
you you miss the earth and so you just
keep orbiting around the earth
um but in that situation everything
around you is sort of falling at the
same rate and so you are effectively
weightless
you are you have essentially zero
gravity because the things the the
gravity of the earth
has sort of the same effect on
everything uh that the
you you're just falling
you're
you're falling in
uh
relative to the earth and everything is
falling with you and so the effect of
gravity
is
there's no there's no pull towards the
earth you don't perceive a pull towards
the earth
now in fact every object
because
the law of gravity is kind of universal
every object that has mass
produces a gravitational attraction
so for example if you have like the
international space station um we'll
have uh
um a certain amount of gravity it has
mass and it will exert a certain
gravitational effect on things around it
i don't know if that gravitational
effect is big enough
um that it is readily observed but
that's that's one of the the things that
one can expect
um there are lots of strange things that
happen
in in microgravity in in essentially
zero uh zero gravity like for example if
you have some water you know we're used
to the fact that you you know you take
some water you pour it out of a glass
you know you you pour it and it will
land in a big puddle
but without gravity that doesn't happen
so instead what happens is water just
forms into big blobs and water the the
surface of the blob has surface tension
so the water the water molecules uh
prefer to be get pulled by other water
molecules and so there's always a force
that's trying to pull the water
molecules together and so if you take a
blob of water the the shape that you'll
get because all the water molecules are
tugging on each other the shape you'll
eventually get is the one that has the
minimum area which is a sphere um and so
that um so
generally what will happen is you put
water in in zero gravity and you just
keep pouring water and it'll make this
so long as
so long as it has no momentum it'll just
make a blob
and you can just take blobs of water and
you can combine them together and so on
if you actually do that i'm told um you
know you can you can like just blow on a
big blob of water and you'll see all
kinds of ripples and then you'll see the
thing you can start for example you can
start the thing rotating by blowing on
one side the water will deform a whole
bunch because it's not a solid object
it's just a liquid and it's only the
only thing that makes it stay a sphere
is the surface tension effect which is
comparatively small so if you sort of uh
if you like a balloon for example uh you
know will tend to say spherical you can
obviously push on one side of it but if
you have a blob of water and you push on
one side of it you really will be able
to deform it greatly i think one of the
things people are afraid of in space
stations and so on is if you take a big
blob of water and you like you know you
hit it hard it will shatter and you have
a lot of little drops and the problem is
that they don't just fall to the ground
and uh you know fall in a big puddle
they get lodged in all kinds of places
and so i gather for example the old mers
space station was just full of random
blobs of water all over the place
they were just hanging out there because
they'd been water that had been leaked
out of something or they spilled
something and it was just a piece of
water there and it was it's not trivial
to go and essentially vacuum up all the
all the pieces of water so that's that's
sort of a phenomenon that happens in
zero gravity and there are lots of
questions like for example when you have
a splash if you throw a sphere of water
at a flat thing or a plate or something
and you see it shatter what will the
shattering look like i think it comes
back in kind of a cone
and then as the cone comes back so the
the the um
the thing
hits and then the water kind of bounces
back and as it bounces back the the rim
of the cone will eventually break up
into all drops
um which is kind of what you see if you
take high-speed flash photography of
kind of a a drop of water or milk or
something
falling into um falling into a uh
falling onto a plate or something like
this or or falling into other liquid but
you see it's very very strange the
pictures that you see it takes only a
thousandth of a second but but um you
know you drop something in in ordinary
gravity on earth you drop a drop into a
uh into into you know a glass of water
or something and what you'll see is the
drop goes in and then actually drop
comes out it bounces back you get this
sort of thing with even with a kind of a
stalk on it that that comes out and you
get the sphere that sort of looks like a
bounced version like your drop just
bounced back out of the water but then
there's also around the edge there's
this thing a so-called corona that forms
that's kind of a crown shape where where
it's kind of like that that
uh that thing i was describing it's kind
of like a cylindrical or conical piece
that comes out it comes back up and then
there's an instability that's that
causes the water when you get the water
is thin around this rim of this kind of
cone or cylinder around that rim the
water tends to sort of because of
surface tension the water there's sort
of an attraction between different
pieces of water and that causes it to
form into different uh eventually form
separate drops and so that's why it's
called the corona because it kind of
ends up having these things where there
are a bunch of little drops formed that
looked like kind of the the points of a
crown so to speak and that's kind of the
the basic structure of splashes
that that structure was discovered
back in late 1800s early 1900s when
people
first started using flash photography
and where you could kind of have a you
kind of see what was happening right
there at the moment of um uh of when the
uh when the when the drop hit the water
and and nowadays you can you can kind of
trigger if you use somewhere you can
just take a video you just look at the
individual frames of the video but if
you're taking a a still photograph you
can just listen for the sound when the
when the drop hits and use that to
trigger your your flash and your camera
and so on
um
let's see
ah there's a comment here about this
effect about the bolt flipping around
um
okay yeah this is it's it's super
confusing what happens and i think it
relates to the cats lying on their feet
as well
if you have a thing that's spinning
around and it's a weird shape you know
if it's a sphere spinning around great
it just spins around if it's a bolt that
has some funny shape it can be spinning
in one direction and spinning in another
direction and the relative effect of the
spinnings in the different directions
has is has a complicated interaction
and that
uh and so you can end up with these with
these sort of
transfer
okay so the the official version of this
is a thing called the moment of inertia
or more officially the inertia tensor
and um let's see can i explain this
uh
well essentially what happens is i
talked about how angular momentum
is just you know when you spin a wheel
around there's an angular momentum
vector the direction it's just one
direction that's kind of oriented along
the axle of the wheel but let's say that
the thing you have isn't like a wheel
it's a much more complicated shape
then the whole idea of hanging momentum
and what's pulling and how and what the
effect of of the motion is is more
complicated and it's described
by this thing called the inertia tensor
that is a
slightly elaborate mathematical object
but the basic point is that the
equations of motion for an object
uh there are definite equations that
describe how the object will move
and
those equations are affected by all the
different pieces of this inertia tensor
so if if you just have something which
is just like a sphere it has a very
simple inertia tensor you have something
that's a weird shape
as it kind of rotates one way but that's
not really it's it what's its real axis
of rotation you have this bolt well if
the bolt is if the axis of rotation is
right along the uh the kind of the shaft
of the boat that's one thing but let's
say the axis of rotation is not aligned
with the shaft of the bolt then you get
effects kind of complicated effects from
from sort of the different pieces of the
bolt that are different distances away
from the from the axis of rotation and
that whole thing produces a fairly
complicated equation of motion that will
cause these these things to kind of like
twist and you know they'll they'll seem
to be moving around in complicated ways
that happened actually on the mer space
station
uh
my friend mike fall who was an astronaut
on the most space station was there when
the things started spinning as a result
of some explosion that happened on it
and it had some complicated motion
because it had multiple different pieces
to its inertia tensor um and uh
gosh i don't remember exactly what
happened but it had um it wasn't just
spinning flat around one axis it was
spinning around multiple axes and doing
have a rather complicated motion
and if it and which made it difficult to
figure out you know do you fire the
rockets just that way but you fire it
just that way to stop the motion from
occurring
um and that this is something people who
do you know gymnastics and things like
this
are are well aware of all these sort of
tricks of changing your moment of
inertia changing in your inertia tensor
which as a human or as a cat for that
matter you can change that inertia
tensor by putting your arms out putting
your arms in if you're a cat sticking
your legs your tail whatever out i mean
a classic effect along those lines is
that um
uh
okay so i talked about conservation of
angular momentum so the angular momentum
is essentially the
the um uh
it's how fast are you going how many
turns are you doing per second but it's
also uh how much mass is how far away
from the axis of rotation
so the angle momentum depends on the
mass the distance you are away from the
axis of rotation and the rate at which
you're rotating
so if you're like spinning around on one
of those you know spinning office chairs
or something
and um you have
you have your arms out
then a bunch of the angular momentum
associated with your spinning will be
okay your arms are out there's a there's
a certain radius and there's a rate of
rotation and so on and you're you're
going to certain rate of rotation you're
going around at a certain speed okay so
you go around that speed then you pull
your arms in
well then
the the angular momentum has to be
conserved but there's a the angular
momentum has a piece that's the rate of
rotation and a piece that's the distance
out to the mass of your of
in your arms and as you reduce that
distance that has to be compensated for
by an increase of the rate of rotation
so you'll tend to go faster as you pull
your arms in and so that that's a sort
of a a standard angular momentum hack um
um
oh my the um
uh yeah alistair here is commenting on
this um
um
on something to do with the um
uh the bolt and space
these geometries get really complicated
it's um
it's uh i always have a hard time
visualizing what happens and even you
know as i mentioned with the top which
is basically something with cylindrical
symmetry um or typical typical top has
cylindrical symmetry that was kind of
the triumph of the late 1800s is working
out the mechanics of those things by the
time you've got something with all these
different shapes and so on yes you can
use mathematica you can do it you can
calculate it it's not actually too hard
even mike foley managed to do it while
he was on the spinning space station
with uh
with a copy of mathematica or language
that he had on a computer there so it
can be done even if you're an astronaut
on a spinning space station but um it's
it's not so such simple math
so
let's see
um
what kinds of questions here
um
oh there's a question in front pocket
will the earth eventually cool down
enough to stop producing a magnetic
field i think the answer to that is yes
i mean the moon for example does not
have a magnetic field the moon does not
have a molten core it doesn't have a
magnetic field
um
and uh there are like jupiter has a very
large magnetic field and it's a probably
a much more complicated situation
where
um i mean jupiter eventually has a has a
jupiter is kind of like a like an owl
it's all feathers and very little body
the the actual um
uh the actual
solid core of jupiter is tiny and it's
probably made of solid hydrogen metallic
hydrogen hydrogen turns into a metal
when it when it becomes solid um the uh
and most of it is gas
um and uh
uh
its magnetic field i assume is
associated with currents with motions
inside that gas
um but i think by the time you are a
a solid solid solid i don't think
that magnetic field will tend to survive
now again having said that that's again
a complicated story because rocks get
magnetized
and so magnetic rocks like magnetite or
some ore of iron or something like this
can get magnetized permanently
magnetized that the magnetism comes from
two basic sources
that we can readily perceive one is when
you have an electric current going
around in a circle like in a coil of
wire that electric current uh will
produce a magnetic field in the along
the axis of the if you have a you know a
spiral of wire that's wound it'll
produce a magnetic field along that axis
that's one effect the other thing is
that electrons
uh even inside atoms can produce a
magnetic field that's pretty much
associated with the fact that the
electrons are going round inside atoms
even the electrons themselves produce
magnetic field but that's even a
different effect
it's probably in the end it's all little
currents going around inside things but
sometimes it's in a big loop of wire and
sometimes it's the electrons moving
inside atoms and so when iron for
example produces magnetic field it's
associated with the electrons moving
around in atoms there and so the the the
the kind of the the magnetic field
that's produced by big motion big
convection cells or other kinds of
motions uh currents basically in the in
the earth currents both in the sense of
electric currents and currents in the
sense of ocean currents you know things
moving around in the earth that's kind
of the large scale way of producing
magnetic field but it's also possible
for rocks to get magnetized and um
that their atoms are lined up in such a
way the electrons that the orientation
of their atoms is such that they uh will
produce a net magnetic field i don't
think any of the known astrophysical
astronomical objects are magnetized that
way um but it's certainly something one
could imagine i mean in in um you know
one could imagine
a um
uh you know a magnetic um uh meteorite
meteorites tend to be quite metallic i
have a little slab of meteorite
somewhere behind me and uh you can you
can put a magnet on it and it's it's
really it's really magnetic it's um it's
uh uh you know back in the day before
people knew how to uh take
the iron that was uh sort of uh sort of
in rock
in iron ore
and they wanted to make a sword or
something out of you know perfect uh you
know
some perfect metallic uh material um if
they would could get that by getting
meteorites that had uh you know metallic
uh that were metallic meteorites and
obviously there wasn't very much of that
so those were pretty rare swords
i am going to have to disappear in a few
minutes here but let's see if we've got
um
um question here about metabolism which
i've tried to address some other time
um
um
suggestions about ai cats here
um
let's see
uh
parker is commenting that tails seem to
be vestigial for many organisms you know
vestigial means it was there once
because it was useful once but now it
isn't useful but the organism didn't
didn't sort of let it
uh
didn't stop producing it
i'm always very suspicious about these
it's vestigial claims
uh biological evolution is fairly
efficient at getting rid of things that
uh
don't make sense so to speak and i tend
to think that most things that are there
are used by the organism for something
or interact with something else
that um
uh
uh you know that the organism does i
mean i i know
a couple months ago i managed to give
myself a repetitive motion injury on my
finger from from rolling a mouse too
much and i i had no idea how many things
one does are affected by you know the
ability to move one finger in a
particular way and somehow these things
that are uh just
you know
it could have evolved differently you
know if we had you know a different
number of fingers or or different joints
in our fingers we would be doing things
differently but given the particular
path we're on things do tend to get used
and i'm i'm um
i think sometimes
the
the it's not obvious what the use is i
mean i think we talked in another one of
these sessions about the human appendix
um which sort of seems like what is it
useful for you know it's just a place
where stuff can get stuck and get
infected and you get appendicitis
but of course in recent times there's
been an increasing realization that all
those bacteria that live in our gut
are are not just sort of a nuisance
they are important to overall health
perhaps not perhaps far beyond just the
way that they are involved with
digestion of food and so on um
perhaps for many other reasons as well
and so it may be very important kind of
to
uh to kind of
garden the the micro the microbes or the
bacteria in your gut to kind of have the
right kind of
you know fertilization of bacteria there
and maybe the appendix is useful because
it you know certain kinds of bacteria
collect there
and they multiply and you end up with
this kind of population versus that kind
of population and so on i mean in the
end the microbiome the kind of the
population of bacteria in our gut it's a
very complicated collection of many many
many different types of bacteria and we
all have different microbiomes and our
microbiomes are continually changing
depending on what we eat and other kinds
of things and you know if we ever take
antibiotics it's you know zaps a huge
fraction of the of the bacteria in our
in our uh in our microbiome and we have
to kind of rebuild those over the course
of time um and uh so it's a it's kind of
a complicated story and i would i would
tend to suspect that
uh you know it's not that you can't do
without that little appendix thing um in
uh but
it it you know it's set up
it ends up being used being sort of
recruited for some purpose
which we can something which we can
describe as a purpose
um that affects the way the microbiome
works
um and uh you know again i i suspect
there are there are many different ways
that the microbiome can be built and
they don't rely on having you know the
appendix there to produce the you know
the fertilizer for the garden or
whatever um but uh but that's sort of a
standard way that it gets done so to say
that it's vestigial isn't quite right
perhaps
um and and and so similarly with tails
it might be that you know a cat uh
you know who knows what the you know
typically what happens in biology is
you'll have something like a tail
and then your first of all the tail will
have evolved because cats with tails
were better hunters let's say than cats
without tails whatever else but then
given that you've got a tail you might
as well use it for communication with
other cats and you know wiggling your
tail around and showing you're happy or
whatever else
i have to say i'm i'm reminded of a
company which i i cannot believe made it
that was a company that was putting
uh motion sensor
accelerometers on the tails of cats and
dogs and it was kind of a it had a cute
name that involved wagging but um the
the idea was that it would have this
accelerometer that was on a that was
attached to the tail of the cat let's
say and that you could kind of translate
from cat ease
by by
monitoring the the uh the motion of the
tail and that would be a uh you know i'm
hungry or don't give me that kind of cat
food again or whatever else um and uh
that would be sort of decoded from the
motion of the tail and i remember i
think those guys were using our machine
learning framework to um to try and
learn
based on sort of the observation of of
acceleration of tales of cats versus the
actual activities of cats could you
decode the tail language of cats
and as i say i'm afraid i don't think
that was a successful startup but um
it's at least an amusing idea to imagine
you know just like we gesture um around
um
in uh you know with our hands
so if you're a cat you're gesturing with
your tail and uh you know can you and i
think for human gesturing um there's
sort of a question
um
the uh
uh you know can we decode the sort of
language of gestures
somebody sent me actually a person who's
a gesture researcher uh sent me
something um a little while ago having
analyzed some videos of me yakking about
things
and um uh
wanting to understand things about sort
of the language of gestures
and uh
one of the questions that that he was
asking was given the gesturing that
somebody does can you tell if the person
is left or right-handed
and so he wants to know what it was for
me and i kind of i don't think he
predicted correctly because i'm
left-handed um but uh
then i got a long essay back about the
details of what really it means to be
left-handed you know about 10 of people
right with their left hands but somebody
like me for example has some
uh
the um
uh
they you know i i write with my left
hand but for certain kinds of large
motor motions i tend to use my right
hand um and uh so that's a sort of a
more complicated case than just i'm
left-handed but i'm right-handed you
know i have to say i just recently uh
i've sequenced my genome for the nth
time i don't know probably fourth or
fifth time now my my whole genome and i
just got back another round of uh
sort of results based on studies that
people have done of genomics
one of those studies said i had a less
than four percent chance to be
left-handed
well i am left-handed not only am i
left-handed but one of my four children
is also left-handed suggesting a genetic
um you know a genetically uh associated
trait of left-handedness there not
certain but um so i i i made it into the
four percent of left-handedness based on
some study that have been done about the
genetics of left-handedness i have to
say and i should probably stop here but
another one of the studies that was in
there was a study that was about
how much people tend to systematize
things
and
it predicted that i had a less than
three percent chance of being a kind of
person who likes to systematize things
which is uh uh amusing because um uh i
spent my life kind of systematizing
things whether it's computational
language or whether it's organizing kind
of
personal systems to to keep myself
efficient and so on so i think um uh the
um
this this less than three percent
thing saying that i was on the
systematizing end of things they didn't
that didn't work for me in that case so
it's kind of the the bottom line there
is just because some study says that
genetics says
that you should be you should have a
high probability for this or that uh
there's more to the story than than uh
what's revealed by these particular
studies of of uh genome association and
so on all right i should wrap up here
for today
and um i think the next few weeks
unfortunately i will be a little bit
spotty in my ability to do these
sessions because um
it is our annual summer school
which i will recommend very highly it's
our project based
we actually have three different
programs okay this is my pitch moment
here
we have three different programs one is
our summer school which is a three week
three week three plus one week uh i
think it has four tracks
science and technology
uh physics our physics project meta
mathematics that was added just this
year an education track for for
educators and so on and kind of the
concept of the summer school is
everybody does a uh
a unique uh kind of original project
in fact i just made the list of
suggested projects for this year uh and
it's like hundreds by i would guess 300
suggestions sadly uh only
there'll be like 70 people or something
at the summer school
from around the world
and um that's uh so not all of those
projects will get done and many of them
uh it will end up being a project that
wasn't even on the list that gets done
by a particular person but anyway our
summer school is for i would say the
center of the distribution is kind of
late undergraduates graduate students
post-docs things like that
we also have our
high school summer camp which is a
two-week program that has the same basic
objectives of doing original project as
the summer school but the projects are
suitable for high school students uh
rather than for uh intended for kind of
the uh uh sophisticated grown-ups so to
speak we occasionally have had high
school students at our summer school
actually as well
uh including some rather notable people
uh who've done that when they've been in
the sort of high school level but our
high school summer camp is intended for
high school students
um we also have a middle school summer
camp for girls that just
that just finished was just last week
and that was a new thing we just added
uh
last year
that's another that's not a project
oriented thing that's um a learning
technology uh kind of thing but anyway
that that's um so the next few weeks is
my
uh my moment um
when i view it as my extreme
professoring
uh weeks of the year
long long ago
i was
oh gosh how long ago is it now
36 years ago
i
was
uh a an actual professor like a
university um i've i've i've not been
doing sort of official professoring ever
since uh these live streams are uh well
one of the things that i do that's kind
of uh
gets my
educational urges
fulfilled so to speak
but another thing which is a more
intense and concentrated one is our
summer school summer camp etc and that's
coming up just the next few weeks
and that usually keeps me rather busy
and we'll have to see what um
what live streams i'm able to fit in we
might even do some
some have some fun and do some live
streams which are combinations of
of um being for you all out in the world
and for local actual people in person um
at our summer school we'll see how that
works out see whether we can get the the
the choreography of that to work but
anyway i should wrap up here uh
for now and um i see there are lots of
interesting questions that um can be
addressed another time
and until then uh